[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of brand new cherry flavor the new
netflix limited series if you haven't
watched the full series come back to
this after for the meantime you can
watch my spoiler free review that is
also on my channel but we're going to be
breaking down every episode here talk
about the whole scene as a whole so make
sure you finish it first before you
watch this
so getting into this this felt like a
limited series that kind of came out of
nowhere for netflix and the trailer
intrigued me because it looked like
something different
something that might be targeted more
towards a niche audience which i think
this definitely
is and this is going to be a polarizing
show where i feel like you're going to
see some people who hate this show but
that's just because it may be not their
cup of tea but i think you also find
people who really love it because it is
their cup of tea i think it's very
important to who this audience kind of
gets out to for it to succeed but
i was excited i love this actress of
rosa salazar you see her
in a lot of animated films and shows
like you know the face so it's cool
to see her kind of in real life doing a
real life role you got the great
katherine keener who's in a similar role
that she's always good at like she
wasn't get out and
eric lang who you might recognize from
another netflix show unbelievable he was
actually the detective so he's
unrecognizable here it shows the range
this actor has
so we'll see with episode one it's a lot
of setup but it's important setup it's
effective setup and it's really
delving into a timely story even though
it takes place in the 90s and this being
based off a novel
it's interesting how they tuned it well
to the times and it's another type of
me too story here with a predator
producer
to this film director aspiring director
and you know this is a story that's very
relatable to a lot of people
in hollywood and getting taken advantage
of and what i did like
was that they kind of did a good job to
show you
how it happens and it's really well done
because you're seeing a lot of stories
are showing these kind of stories now
but they did in a way that was clear
like oh yeah this is a believable way
how these situations come about why
someone feels the victim in that
situation
and what the bad intentions are and how
someone takes advantage of being
powerful like this producer played
brilliantly by eric lang but what i did
really like about this first episode was
that
when she is betrayed by him right when
lisa nova our main character goes back
to him is like i want to hear you say it
she just doesn't even want an apology
she wants to know what changed where you
were my mentor we were going through
with all this gonna have this movie made
and clearly we're gonna get that payoff
now with that line
in the finale which i really appreciate
i love when things are planned out that
well
and you get that feeling like you were
paid off as an audience to get that
answer
from lou burke but you know that's what
we'll get out later where he's like in
the finale that it made him feel small
that when he put his hand on her legs
she rejected him and this
again explains intentions of why people
do what they do
and not justifying it but showing you
why this happens and why it hurts people
and
how these messy situations come about so
i think they did a really good job at
that
and they did it in a great dressing here
of this like david lynch-esque
vibe but where i'm so so myself about
david lynch what i think they did great
with the david lynch vibe is that
everything that was
weird here and odd and strange had a
purpose in the story
it was justifiable there was a reason it
wasn't being weird to just be weird
which i will say sometimes with david
lynch i think happens
and you're obviously going to get a kind
of john wick vibe this is based in a
revenge story so
right away in this first episode say set
that up she
is on this revenge and she meets boro
who
is played by catherine keener and she's
like this witch but really she's that
storyline of making a deal with the
devil
but what hooks you in in a first episode
like this is that
they give you stuff that's new and
unique and maybe this story can be
similar
parts to other things you've seen
obviously but having her puke out
kittens you know having a different type
of mysterious character
in the borough and that katherine keener
puts a different spin on her to make her
own
i like that i think there is something
here that keeps you intrigued because
you
feel like you're getting something that
was trying to be out of the box but in a
good way so
i think the first episode it's a lot of
setup so it might not be the most
entertaining but i'm giving 8.6 is
effective premiere so we go to episode
two this is where
the horror vibes of the show really
starts kicking in it doesn't really
happen episode one but i'm so too like
oh okay
and little stuff set up already here
even in this episode like we learned
that
lisa's mom left her you know as a baby
which we'll get to in payoffs with that
but i like that they blended humor here
well where
didn't take away from what was happening
in the seriousness of it all but it
added you know and
complimented it i like that she needed a
photo of lou but a pinch of his pubic
hair and i love how they just talk about
getting this pubic hair throughout
episode it added that humor to it but i
love again this horror coming as we
first see this entity figure that looks
like something out of a guillermo del
toro film
which was really cool and had cool like
creature vibes and sounds to it i really
like that
it's like the psychedelic horror you get
throughout this show which i thought was
effective
and the lighting in particular was great
in the show i love how they use the
colors of red throughout and we see
you know being cherry flavor of this
show but you see the character lisa is
always wearing red until the end when
she changes which we'll get to but the
lighting is expressing her mood which i
really appreciate
and what's really good about the acting
here across the board for
rosa salazar as lisa nova is she is a
different level of talent because she
just has
it you know like she has that presence
on the screen like i think she's worthy
of saying she's a great lead and it was
good that she could show it off in the
show but i thought one of her standout
scenes when she was actually
you know doing this ritual with boro to
make the connection with lou i thought
it was really well done by rosa here
and it's a good cliffhanger having see
that boro
drinks the blood of the kittens and her
pupils dilates so it works for that
netflix type of binge
and they add intrigue now because you're
sort of trusting borrow and you're not
and having the characters in the jail
tell lisa like don't make a deal with
borrow it's a bad history already gets
you like okay who
is the villain in the story who is the
good guy and that was
smart how this show went about where
they eventually get to a point where it
feels like breaking bad where this
character lisa you sympathize with you
know you
you do less and less as it goes on and
she kind of breaks bad in her own way
and it will serve the theme
well and it will become an anti-hero
story again which
we'll see as it goes on but episode 2 i
thought was really good too and again
bringing that horror and effect of humor
i'm giving it an 8.8 episode 3 is the
shortest episode of 36 minutes but this
is where the revenge really
story kicks in now and the character of
losers getting these hiccups at the bar
again which i liked it was like a good
villain tick for a bit too that it's
just giving him interest as a character
to watch and him have to hiccup through
everything
and that he kind of slowly gets a little
bit of good graces from lisa because
she's talking up her film to these
producers but again she can't trust this
guy
turns out he's totally betrayed her and
is showing her film at this party but i
love
especially the lighting in the scene
when she gets that anger you know the
red lighting comes over her she's going
through a red hallway she's in this red
dress
and it actually leads to one of the best
scenes on the show was this very
tense scene with her and lou and she's
trying to get him to you know snort the
coke with the worm in it and by this
point i'm just very impressed by the
directors working on the show
creators the writers like this is
something that's different it's exciting
team
of talent here and i'm excited to see
what they make next but i was impressed
like i was like okay these are
good writers good directors they're
following just basics to make something
at least decent and they're going beyond
decent here which i thought was really
cool and there you could see they're
trying to make something different
but you start to see that anti-hair
thing start to come into play a bit and
how far is too far where when she's
staring down
jewels borrows behind her and he lights
on fire at the pool
again this was her friend who betrayed
her who took on the movie and you start
to wonder now is she going too far and
going down the deep end but i'm gonna
give this episode 8.2 wasn't as good as
the first two again it might just be
hurt by its length and how short it was
but
still good now episode four is where
stuff starts to flip
and things you thought were happening
are changing and
you get to see that boro is not this
good person at
all that she really is a villain by
nature and she's really got no side in
any fight with the people around her she
just does what helps her the best and
true which form
we see that the problem with lisa's deal
that she made is
that to get revenge on lou it's not in
the clean way where it would just hurt
lou it's hurting people around him
which she doesn't want to hurt his son
and you know it goes to extremes where
it's affecting people she didn't think
it would affect
this was my favorite episode of the
series though it has so many moving
parts to it
and lisa is getting sicker and sicker so
there's just tension built throughout
the episode and
it leads to this great eerie basement
scene when we first go through the trap
door
and she finds the loose eyeball which
eventually learns was mary's eye
the actress and we see the first time
the lady with the ripped out face which
we'll know later on
is a form of her mother through this
jaguar and
it was all scary and terrifying i
thought that was really cool to see
i love little details in the lines too
where you see like basically
lou's house everything is going crazy
with these animals and he's like you're
stressing out the falcons that he loves
and he's like their elite predators of
course the elite predator himself saying
that
an arachnophobia alert because i am a
fellow arachnophobia
that giant tarantula oh my god that
freaked me out
and we saw a lot of it so fair warning
but yeah then jonathan
gets this like killer erection from the
spider bite that was even hinted at by
lisa earlier but just to the wrong
person now where i think
this show is going to be polarizing and
it gets just really
you know weird but i liked it i think
that's what you know if you're watching
the show it's what you want right
is when we get this crazy body horror
which was a sick scene to me when the
kitten was coming out of lisa's side we
get this uh
sex scene with her and roy and he's like
putting his fingers
in the side where the kittens coming out
so that's the scene i think
will probably turn people off who aren't
into the really extreme weird stuff like
this is what i'm saying it's very niche
i think that's something that will you
know probably tune a lot of people out
but if you're into it
you're like okay we're going full here
so i do appreciate that i thought it was
cool
i mean it's it's craziness like that's
what this show is and it was embracing
that and i thought
i loved the character of roy because you
know what makes shows a lot of
predictable now is that like every
single guy in it is a villain or he
turns out betrays
the lead female and he's bad this is a
case where i was like showing you okay
there's still some you know good guys
out there so this was a good guy in roy
and i think they stayed true to that and
i i thought that was
brought the fresh air because it took
away from you know like worrying like oh
he's just gonna turn bad
and it took away from it being
predictable in that sense so i like that
i thought that was nice and they did a
good job
in building a relationship with her and
roy and one of my favorite humorous
moments in the show is
when you know he's like you're just
producing kittens now and they're in
this motel
and the guy just shows up the zombie
motorcycle guy just take the
kitten and she's just like yeah he's
just taking the dead i o i
just thought that was great and how it
was delivered by rosa herself so
casually but
really i'm excited when we actually see
lou shows up to
borrow here and they have this kind of
showdown
and testing each other out but it's two
great actors working together and just
works so well to me
i will have a little complaint though
there's a lot of convenience sometimes i
cheat in the script like
it does get ridiculous at a point that
anyone can just walk into borrow's place
at any time even though she's doing
these crazy things like it just could
have took one person to call like
you know anyone the police are even just
like you could burn this witch hut down
if you know there's all these awful
things like it's strange she's so open
to it and then like when they actually
come to get lisa at one point lou and
mary
that they are blocked off and they have
all these zombie guards but most of the
time she just doesn't care i just
thought that was inconsistent and that
even goes to
there's a line they'll show in an
episode or two coming up
where you know lisa we find out she's
living in this apartment building alone
but no one else lives in the apartment
building so it's like that's a
convenient way to get away from
trappings of people seeing like what's
going on in this crazy apartment is kind
of like okay but i don't buy that there
would just be
in a way for her to live in an apartment
building all alone with no one else
like come on but that's nitpicking but
episode four was my favorite by far
again it just everything was clicking so
much happening and it was all really
fascinating so i'm giving that one a 9.2
now episode 5
is where we're really going to borrow
and you know learning all about boro's
past but also
she sees the character of jennifer the
body she's taken over
the family she left behind right so we
learned this family was looking for her
for 10 years i did think it was strange
that the husband we meet
had like no ecstatic reaction to seeing
her again
in the first time in 10 years he was
just like oh hi you know that was so
weird to me i didn't think that worked i
didn't think it made sense with the kids
because they didn't really grow up with
her they were too young but with him it
was just strange
how they had the character and actor
react to her for the first time seeing
her in 10 years
and like i said you're gonna see scenes
that are really odd like basically
boro you know poisons all them at the
table not too strong not to kill them
but to make them forget everything and
she does this like brain surgery thing
to make them forget
and that could be seen as really weird
and just to be weird but it's not it's
still serving the plot
it makes sense for the character of boro
to do something like this so that's what
i thought was
really well done by the show and
probably the strongest thing because a
lot of times people
just do weird stuff to be weird but this
show really knew how to make it all
count
and have a purpose and it's so awful and
mean what borrow does because you know
jennifer's former family doesn't
remember each other when they wake up so
it's sad you know
it's cruel but i really know the
standout scene acting wise was between
lisa and lou when he comes and yells at
her at the hospital what happened to her
son
and you're starting to see the gray
start that really happened with lisa and
guilt hitting lisa like
again jules even though he sucked for
taking your film he doesn't deserve to
be like
basically paralyzed and jonathan did
nothing to her and his
life is she's dead basically so you know
all this stuff's kind of hitting her now
i thought this scene was really intense
and shot really well when the henchman
goes to
kill lisa and he beats her up he's an
awful henchman though because he doesn't
actually check he killed her because he
didn't but jonathan's watching it's
really cool he's like creepily watching
from down the hallway and the lights are
flickering and again just amazing acting
by rosa here so i'm gonna give this one
8.7 now this is where my criticisms come
in episodes six and seven i did not
really like of this show which was
surprising because usually shows get
better as they go on but i thought
six and seven were the weakest i think
this episode struggled a bit because we
had a lot of exposition which is
important of boro explaining her past
with this jaguar
it's a little hard to follow but again
fine it's a lot of telling maybe i would
like to see some of it
but again fine that's hard to pull off
but something about it just didn't click
to me
like thinking it was like the best way
to present this information with her
just telling her while you know rose is
just laying in this milk hot tub
basically
and then even the story about the peyote
in the woods with mary when they filmed
it i wanted to know
more too about what was really happening
or see more what was happening with
lisa here with mary when she was
actually filming her on this p.o day
both of them and her freaking out and
cutting her eye out and keeping it on
film i wanted to see a little more to it
and get to know a little bit not a lot
just a little bit more about lisa in
this time frame but we do see there were
lovers here but this is the first
episode that felt silly
to me i mean even lisa when she's eating
this henchman there's not much reaction
to her
eating this henchman and even to herself
doing it like i feel like they kind of
left that away
and never came back to it and this felt
a little generic and cliche this episode
where
code really takes on the only sensible
one here to set up his death
paying off more you really do like code
and i really like the actor of code i
thought he was a great character too
but it just felt like they're trying to
get rid of this body and it kind of just
felt like it slowed up a lot of the
momentum here and
that felt like something you've seen a
lot before and even roy just saying he's
gonna leave her now
after all this stuff like really fast a
lot of character moments were rushed in
this episode and in a way
it also felt slow too and sloppy so this
one just felt
off being as tight as the previous
episodes and then episode 7 being a
penultimate episode was a disappointment
because that's usually when shows are at
their best but this is where i got
annoyed with this plot they threw in
where
the uncle and the henchman who got
killed is on his quest to get his
revenge with a machete on lisa i don't
even think this was necessary i do think
this was a plot trick that he was to get
lisa into the basement and get things
set up in the finale where
at the same time you could have done
other ways like why even have his
character be another
sector of this story i thought it was
distracting like who cares
and why i'm gonna give props to the
actor so much eric lang of lou burke is
somehow this guy we've seen on awful
things he's not a good person you still
sort of feel for him when he's with his
son in these scenes with his son i did
like those scenes at the restaurant in
particular
and that's all acting there so props to
him for that and what i didn't like in
inconsistencies here is that we see
the sex magic the blood magic needs to
happen it makes like this omelet with
all that she has to eat to get rid of
this poison in her from licking the toad
but i did not understand maybe i missed
it but when she went in the basement
she sees the woman who's her mother aka
really the jaguar behind all this
you know they mentioned one point oh and
the poison's gone she didn't eat the
omelet so what
how did the poison leave that was
confusing to me i felt like that was a
cheat but this is where lisa's really
you know
her character grows a bit because she
says i feel like i traded his life for
my movie talking about code so losing
code was
effective was a big part for her
character and really code was her soul
at the end of the day even over roy and
for her losing code she knew like she
was
too far gone just to get what she wanted
with her movie and revenge
and even it didn't really make sense
that in this basement there's a red door
that you think was gonna maybe go in a
different time
or different area dimension but it just
gets her out of conveniently the
basement so she doesn't run into the
henchmen that got her into the basement
so
that was sloppy too it was just like
okay this is just a red door that's
conveniently in the basement that gets
you out of the basement so
that was strange and i thought it didn't
really land this last part where
roy's like i want my golden globe meets
up elise when she comes out of the red
door
just brings her to regular time and
regular place and the henchman's
shooting at them from the window and the
in the limo and it awkwardly just ends
the episode i was like okay that didn't
really get me excited for the finales
decent so i'm going to give the pen
ultimate 7.4 but now we go the finale
and i was worried because it was like i
feel like the show was dropping off a
bit in quality but then
i thought this was a really strong
finale which made me really happy and it
had a nice bow on it and i mean what's
better than opening episode with
catherine keener talking to a couch i
thought that was great you know it's the
white jaguar i thought that was just one
of those moments in
in cinema you just love to see but we
see lisa at the top of this episode
she's
still on a revenge patch she's like
first i'm going to kill luna and take
care of boro
and i thought this really worked well
the scene with her showing up to lou's
place because
lou's begging her now just to kill him
and he thinks he just
she just wants him to apologize but what
really paid off into this whole story
was what was set up like i said in the
beginning where she's like no i just
want you to say it what changed
what changed from us having this team
making this movie and he
admits his pathetic ways that he felt
small when she basically rejected him so
i thought that really paid off and it
shows she grew
because by her doing all these things to
get revenge on him
the end of the day she pulls this worm
out of his eye but she spares him and
lets him live
so that comes around too when she visits
him in the hospital and
it shows a growth in her character in
maturity and seeing what she's done a
self-realization that she
went too far and did the wrong move on
this and that getting what you want
cause he's like are you happy you got
your movie back
and all these people are hurt around you
it's like no it doesn't bring you what
you thought
and you see too when mary is now buying
time when
lisa shows up to borrows for borrow to
really
take care of lisa here she's like you
just used me in this film
you pushed me too far i took my eye out
and you kept it in the film which is the
worst thing out of all these things lisa
did is just awful like
keeping on the film for her own success
so she's got
a dirty past as well she's not this
innocent person you thought in the
beginning and that's what i think works
so well in the writing of this character
our main character because it's showing
you by the end of this
everything she did from what we knew
about in the beginning was different we
knew about her at the end and that
it shows how far a character has come
because she already was doing messed up
stuff
before all this stuff with lou so she
came to this self-realization at the end
and she left her film in the apartment
and she's offered everything she wanted
from alvin the producer and she's gonna
direct
and that's what she originally wanted
too but the change was when she realized
not to take that call and take the
luncheon to get the actress
and she goes home what really should
matter to her and
finding herself and not wearing red
anymore walking into this white
into brazil i thought that really landed
and worked well and it pushes that
lesson of the story which you've seen a
lot before but i think it works because
we really like the character of lisa and
then you had that breaking bad feel of
that anti-hero where you start going
like ooh i don't know anymore and then
you learn more about her from the past
you don't like about
her but you see a character that grew
and changed and got what they needed in
the end and that's what's
really good with writing is you know she
wanted something she wanted revenge but
at the end they got what they needed
so not what they wanted so i thought
that was you know
really really great and let's just say
the best
moment body horror wise and gore was
really ripped roy's head off that was
insane and i was like okay now we know
where we're going because they're
killing everyone here around her and
it was effective with her crying great
performance again by rosa when she saw a
code
in his one eye and dead he's a zombie
now all these people's
lives she cared about she ruined and to
just top it off that cherry
no pun intended was with roy's head
getting ripped off
now what was really interesting to me
was
this is a limited series you know we'll
see how the reaction is by people and
how well it does on netflix but they did
they wrapped in a nice bow but they left
the door open because we see
voro took over mary's body and now
boro is in mary's body so they've left
the villain of borrow the door open they
could do another story for sure so we'll
see
but they've definitely wrapped this
story of lisa
um so i thought that was interesting if
they want to make another series of the
show maybe they do
like anthology but with the character of
boro as this
witch that could be cool but they
definitely have to door for a sequel if
it does really well i think for sure so
the strong finale is a whole i'm gonna
give it an 8.7
that brought my score up but the show is
a whole i'm gonna give the show as a
whole an 8.5
i think it's right just that b and i
think
the best part about it it's different it
had a nice bow to it a strong theme
again about just taking revenge
too far and it keeps the world spinning
the wrong way if we all just
try to do bad things to get back at
someone who hurt us
instead of just trying to grow and do it
a different way because then you end up
hurting other people you just keep the
chain going i think that's what the show
was definitely
pushing at and it was shown really well
through this character of lisa
but that she could change and grow and
realize what happened here to herself
from her past and then in this story we
see it and into her come around by the
end so
i really like that and i think that it
is niche like it's going to be
polarizing again
come on him putting his fingers in that
side of her where the cat came out you
know
that's gonna be one of those just
polarizing things you're either in
you're out at that point so
again i think you're just gonna hear so
many mixed opinions about this just by
bias though like what you're into but if
you're this is your type of cup of tea
where it's
weird strange and it's you know pretty
horrifying and
just i think the best part was the good
writing and the great acting of course
and
just stand out for rosa salazar here but
that's also you know eric lang and
catherine keener also did great so he
had three great
lead performances so i was impressed i i
didn't have high expectations for this
but i
really liked it and i'm interested to
hear what you guys think so let me know
down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment and try to
respond as many
as i can please make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss one of my reviews i do
celebrity interviews as well and if you
really like what i do here i appreciate
every time for a membership because hit
the join button it will help me do this
full time one day
and get more stuff out for you guys and
please follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time